c'est à minsk aussi essayiste
spécialiste de la politique tunisienne
dans les présidentielles on a remarqué
que façade qui est un candidat très
atypique qui prône une décentralisation
massive et qui incarne ce changement
voulu par les tunisiens mais dans les
législatives on a retrouvé des scores
assez classique si ce n'est la montée du
parti des storia libre qui est du coup
une partie ouvertement benalistes et qui
quelque chose de très nouveau en tunisie
étant donné que depuis 2011
les gens qui croyaient avoir le monopole
du pays pendant la dictature se sont
retrouvés avec des scores très
infligeant aux premières élections et
aux seconds de 2014 les partis ont une
très mauvaise image en tunisie
d'ailleurs la participation aux
élections présidentielles étaient bien
plus l'autre aux élections législatives
et là on retrouve avec l'histoire faire
une sorte de désaveu des partis parce
que ce café prayssas et c'est de choisir
quelqu'un qui n'a une amie qui n'était
d'aucun partir elle à l'assemblée et a
presque a fait l'espoir fait c'est ici
de nier le processus le processus
démocratique en tunisie où il faut une
majorité pour gouverner et il ya ce
revers a essayé de d'exclure si l'on
veut le parti dominant dans cette
majorité et chose intéressante aussi
c'est que tout ce qui nous arrive depuis
quelques mois est assez différente des
instabilités qu'on a connu auparavant
entre 2014 et 2016 et la vraie question
c'est de celui à mon sens de se dire
pourquoi
récemment c'est devenu plus radicale où
on essaye de les conflits sont devenus
assez violent même identitaire et c'est
là qu'on peut par exemple pointé du
doigt ce qu'a fait il espère faire
aujourd'hui
en renvoyant le ministère des affaires
étrangères et on peut se dire que le
contexte libyen une grande influence sur
ce qui se passe actuellement en tunisie